hi this is kim from khan academy and
today i'm learning more about the fifth
amendment to the u.s constitution the
fifth amendment is one of the better
known constitutional amendments since we
frequently hear references to suspects
taking the fifth in tv shows and movies
but what does it actually mean to take
the fifth to learn more i talked to two
experts donald dripps is the warren
distinguished professor of law at the
university of san diego school of law
and steven salzburg is the wallace and
beverly woodbury university professor of
law at george washington law school so
professor salzburg could you talk a
little bit about why the framers were
interested in choosing to protect these
rights in particular
the fifth amendment really addresses
four different things one it says that
generally you can't be charged with a
serious crime unless you're indicted by
a grand jury two it says you can't be
subjected to double jeopardy three it
says you can't be compelled to be a
witness against yourself
and four
there is this due process right not to
be deprived of life liberty or property
without due process if you look at it
the three provisions the grand jury
provision double jeopardy and the
privilege against self incarnation all
have a common history and that is that
in england there was a time at which the
the crown the king basically tried to
assert power to bringing people
to trial for charges the king wanted
brought
and the grand jury
served as a protection between the king
and ordinary people
most of the provisions in the bill of
rights are aimed at preventing the
recurrence of some specific abuse that
had been known to english history
there are different provisions in the
fifth amendment that speak to different
abuses the fundamental one and the one
that goes furthest back in the legal
history back to magna carta and so on is
the due process clause and that clause
means that
no person can be injured by the
government
except according to the law of the land
and after a fair trial and that
in the very very distant past back in
the 13th century king john had an
infamous practice of executing uh
supposed rebellious barons and then
holding a solemn trial after the drawing
and quartering
and so that notion of a judgment before
uh punishment
is is really really fundamental
that's what due process is about at its
most basic level
interesting so can you say more about
the due process clause here what is due
process
due process is an extraordinarily
complicated concept it means that there
are certain procedural and substantive
rules that must be honored in the way in
which governments approach individuals
and entities that
they seek to regulate it's not a simple
bright line that in order to have due
process this is what is required due
process is somewhat flexible it tends to
provide more protections when
individuals are faced with more serious
consequences so in terms of criminal law
it's generally understood that the most
severe penalties that we have that can
legally be imposed upon people are the
death penalty prison and jail and
generally you can't impose any of those
except as a punishment for a crime and
so the
due process in the criminal arena is
largely defined by
the bill of rights and some
common law
understandings that have been carried
forward
let me give you a couple of examples
there is nothing in the constitution
that says the government must prove
guilt in a criminal case beyond a
reasonable doubt but that is a
fundamental part of american law the
supreme court has held that that is part
of what due process
requires and that is the law throughout
the united states notwithstanding the
fact you don't see it in the
constitution similarly the right to a
unanimous jury
in a criminal case is also not found
anywhere in the constitution you
mentioned a grand jury so how is that
different from an ordinary jury um the
grand jury
served a a very delicate role
in founding error times because many
many prosecutions were brought by
private persons there were no police
forces of the modern paramilitary 24 7
type
and a lot of law enforcement was done by
self-help
and
prosecutions were privately funded um
and sometimes uh lay people would
represent themselves pro se in pressing
a criminal prosecution and the grand
jury was there to make sure that people
weren't subjected to
vindictive or malicious prosecutions by
their by you know ill-spirited neighbors
and that sort of thing um the framers
probably had in mind the famous case of
the earl of shaftesbury who was
suspected
of
misdeeds and a grand jury famously
refused to indict him um and so they saw
it as one among many checks against the
possible
abuse of power by this new federal
government so a grand jury is a body
that decides whether or not to bring a
charge against an individual or an
entity like a corporation the grand jury
in federal court happens to be 23 people
but there isn't anything in the
constitution that actually says it has
to be that number unlike a trial jury
which we call a petty jury the grand
jury does not have to be unanimous it
basically decides whether to bring a
charge by a majority vote and the grand
jury is
specifically instructed that its job is
not to decide guilt or innocence
its job is to decide whether there is
sufficient evidence to bring a charge
which we usually say means probable
cause to believe that a crime was
committed and a particular person
committed that crime so the grand jury's
function is to bring a charge
the trial jury's function is to then
decide guilt and or innocence
interesting so how about double jeopardy
this is something that i think we have a
maybe rudimentary understanding of in
popular culture what does double
jeopardy really mean
if we didn't have a double jeopardy
clause the executive branch if it could
persuade a grand jury to charge somebody
with a crime could prosecute that person
and if the person was acquitted the
government could do it again bring the
same charge do it again until they got a
conviction and that meant that an
individual could be persecuted rather
than prosecuted by continuing charges
for the exact same thing and the basic
function of the double jeopardy clause
is to basically tell the government you
get one shot trials are very stressful
and very expensive and the government
has more resources than the typical
defendant does and so one concern is
that you would just have the government
have power to bankrupt people by
retrying the case
over and over again
it becomes very very complicated saying
just what the same offense is the the
current doctrine is that every statutory
crime
that's
includes different factual elements than
every other statutory crime arising out
of the same course of conduct as a
separate crime are there any exceptions
to double jeopardy or common
misconceptions about how it works
yes there are two
common misconceptions
one of them
is that you can only be tried once for
the same criminal activity and
the reason you can actually be
prosecuted more than once is because in
our system federal government and each
state is considered to be a separate
sovereign which means
the federal government can charge
someone with a crime let's say a drug
conspiracy the state of virginia or
california
can also prosecute for the same criminal
conduct
the states have their own
criminal law to enforce
so
technically someone could be prosecuted
let's say
by the commonwealth of virginia for a
drug conspiracy and convicted and then
could be prosecuted again by the federal
government or another state for the same
criminal activity
and be convicted or acquitted
and the double jeopardy cause would not
be violated the second thing
about double jeopardy
is that it only protects you from
being prosecuted a second time by the
same sovereignty
for the same crime it doesn't protect
you
from being prosecuted for a different
crime suppose the state of california
prosecutes
a defendant for murder and the defendant
is acquitted the state of california
could then bring a second prosecution
for a kidnapping of the same victim
that actually occurred before the murder
and because that's a different crime
the double jeopardy cause doesn't bar
a separate prosecution so there's also a
clause here that says an individual
shall not be compelled in any criminal
case to be a witness against himself
so this is what we call taking the fifth
right what does that mean
so the fifth amendment privilege
is a privilege that can be asserted by
anyone who is called to answer by agents
of the government
and to claim the privilege it it has to
be the case that the witness
is being compelled to speak will suffer
adverse consequences if she doesn't
answer the questions the government
officers want her to answer those
answers have to tend to incriminate
the witness and those answers have to be
testimonial that is to say they have to
in some way constitute witnessing
good lawyers good lawyers will generally
advise their clients to take the fifth
that is claim their privilege against
self-incrimination almost any time that
the government is seriously
investigating them and the reason is
people's memories are often bad that
when people are asked questions they may
believe that something happened in a
certain way but they haven't gone back
to review it and
when people make mistakes
simple mistakes
that are made in response to a question
may look like people deliberately lie
they may
make someone look like they were
attempting to deceive investigators and
therefore when in doubt individuals who
are being investigated have good reason
to invoke their privilege against
self-incrimination historically there
were two things that the fifth amendment
privilege was really supposed to prevent
one was that while the english system
relied on grand juries and petty juries
and and cross-examination
confrontational trials uh the european
system of the founding era in the is
even as late as as the end of the 18th
century still relied on juridical
torture so if there was a lot of
preliminary proof about against a super
probable cause against a suspect in say
france or germany the judges were
authorized to torture
the target into confessing they wanted
to adopt this the inquisitorial
practices of continental europe and the
other great abuse behind the privilege
was the court of star chambers use of
the the oath ex-officio which was
witnesses were called before the star
chamber without knowing what the
investigation was about whether they
were a target what they were suspected
of doing and the first thing that
happened was they were obliged to swear
an oath and there was a famous case
involving a man named john wilburn who
refused to take the oath and was
torturously punished by the court of
star chamber for refusing to take that
oath they they pilloried him and they
flogged him and his case was seen as
kind of an example of uh
the kinds of abuses that might be done
by asking questions uh subject to to to
oaths where the answer might incriminate
you or expose you to perjury uh or
expose your soul to eternal consequences
and so those two things were behind the
privilege against self-incrimination
that the founders didn't want either of
those to
to come back from the past to haunt the
new continent say that i've committed a
crime what might happen are police
or investigators required to tell me
about my right not to self-incriminate
starting in 1966
in the case that many people have now
heard of miranda versus arizona the
united states supreme court held that
when a person is in custody that is
generally has been arrested and the
investigators or prosecutors want to
question the suspect they have to give a
series of warnings which are widely
known as the miranda warnings in short
they have to say to the suspect you have
the right to remain silent anything you
say can and will be used against you in
a court of law you have the right to
have a lawyer present during any
questioning and if you cannot afford a
lawyer one will be appointed for you
when the when the suspect is in custody
they have to give the famous miranda
warning that everybody knows from movies
and television and so forth and that
that's the one case where the government
is required to be proactive in front of
a congressional committee or a grand
jury investigation
or if you're just a witness at a civil
trial and there's a question that might
expose you to criminal liability um you
have to claim the privilege you have to
say i refuse to answer that question on
the grounds that it may incriminate me
when the suspect is under arrest
and the police want to question him they
have a different
duty they have a duty to proactively
give him a warning to make sure that he
understands his rights that he doesn't
have to say anything uh to the police
that what he does say could be
admissible against him
so we've learned that the fifth
amendment protects citizens from
possible abuses of power by the
government when an individual is charged
with a crime it requires a grand jury to
determine whether an individual should
be indicted for a crime limits the
number of times an individual can be
tried for the same crime protects people
from self-incrimination and requires
that the government follow fair
procedures in prosecuting the law to
learn more about the fifth amendment
visit the national constitution center's
interactive constitution and khan
academy's resources on u.s government
and politics